Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
La popolazione del genere umano nel mondo,
negli ultimi duemila anni,
è sempre stata relativamente piccola:
non più di un centinaio
di milioni di persone.
Poi, circa 150 anni fa,
è successo qualcosa:
la Rivoluzione Industriale,
l’invenzione dei vaccini
e degli antibiotici
e tante altre cose
hanno creato una vera e propria
esplosione demografica.
In 150 anni, da poche centinaia di milioni
oggi sulla Terra siamo
più di sette miliardi.
Bello.
Ma questi sette miliardi
consumano tantissimo
e bruciano tantissimo petrolio,
carbone, gas naturale.
E questo ha creato
un problema molto grosso,
che potete vedere illustrato
in maniera estremamente sintetica
in questa figura.
Essenzialmente, in 150 anni
abbiamo bruciato combustibili fossili
per un equivalente di 2000
Giga Tonnellate di CO2,
di gas a effetto serra.
Purtroppo, questo ha comportato
l'innalzamento della temperatura
media del pianeta
di più di un grado, che è tantissimo.
Ora, il genere umano
ha un grosso problema:
noi sappiamo che non possiamo
assolutamente superare
i più due gradi di
riscaldamento del pianeta;
e quindi, in qualche modo il genere umano
ha una sorta di budget residuo
di circa 1500/2000 Giga Tonnellate di CO2.
Ma la cosa più inquietante,
preoccupante, che pochi sanno,
è che questo budget corrisponde
a una piccolissima frazione -
molto meno del dieci per cento -
di tutto quello che è l'equivalente
di petrolio, carbone, gas naturale.
La morale è che il genere umano
dovrà fare un enorme sforzo
di lasciare sottoterra,
e resistere alla tentazione di [estrarre]
tutta questa immensa quantità
di combustibili fossili
che potrebbe trasformarsi in CO2,
e quindi in innalzamento
della temperatura.
Tutti i settori industriali, oggi,
stanno cercando di affrontare
questo enorme problema che l'umanità ha.
In particolare il settore
della mobilità, dei trasporti,
che è responsabile di circa
il 25-30 percento di queste emissioni,
sta cercando di transitare
da un vecchio modello di mobilità,
che essenzialmente possiamo sintetizzare
in macchine grosse,
a combustibile fossile,
di proprietà personale,
ovviamente guidate da umani,
a un nuovo modello di mobilità
completamente diverso,
in cui le auto saranno, mediamente,
molto più piccole,
elettriche o a idrogeno,
condivise e a guida autonoma.
Questi sono i cosiddetti quattro
mega trend della mobilità,
quello che succederà
nei prossimi 20, 30 anni.
Volevo però sottolineare
che ne esiste uno di questi
che è un po' speciale:
l'automazione della guida.
L’automazione della guida,
infatti, è molto speciale
perché fungerà come una sorta
di catalizzatore.
Infatti accelererà la transizione
verso una mobilità a servizio -
quindi non più auto di proprietà,
ma un'auto diciamo condivisa
che noi useremo come un'auto pubblica -
che poi a sua volta accelererà
il processo di riduzione delle dimensioni
e il completamento del processo
di elettrificazione.
Quindi, in qualche modo,
l'automazione del guidatore, dell'auto,
sarà una sorta di big bang
di questa rivoluzione
nella mobilità del futuro.
Bene.
Quello che succederà, come conseguenza,
è che ci sarà una sorta di biforcazione.
Oggi in Italia ci sono
quaranta milioni di automobili.
E sono automobili private
che assolvono sia aspetti funzionali,
quindi vado da A a B,
e anche hanno un aspetto
legato al piacere di guida,
al piacere del possesso.
Questi due aspetti si biforcheranno,
e verranno nitidamente attribuiti:
uno a delle auto, che chiamiamo robotaxi,
che avranno un aspetto
puramente funzionale,
quindi saranno auto autonome,
condivise, puramente funzionali;
poi ci sarà una piccola nicchia
di auto emozionali,
che probabilmente resteranno
di proprietà privata,
sicuramente rimarranno non autonome,
e assolveranno un obiettivo,
essenzialmente,
di piacere di guida, del piacere
di possedere l'automobile.
Vi faccio osservare che questa transizione
avrà un importantissimo effetto
di efficientamento della mobilità.
Dicevo: in Italia oggi ci sono
40 milioni di automobili.
Passando a questo modello
di mobilità condivisa e autonoma,
questo numero diventerà verosimilmente
solo quattro - cinque milioni,
quindi un enorme efficientamento
e risparmio di risorse
rispetto a questo enorme
numero di automobili
che oggi occupano il territorio,
e sono essenzialmente poco utilizzate.
Come si fa vedere questo numero,
questa riduzione di un fattore dieci?
Lo si può fare in maniera
molto sofisticata,
oppure in maniera semplice,
per dare l'idea,
semplicemente guardando
la contemporaneità di utilizzo
nell'ora di punta.
Prendete un qualunque giorno feriale,
tra le sette e le otto,
e scoprite che, in realtà,
solo il dieci per cento delle automobili
sono contemporaneamente usate.
Questo è il picco
di utilizzo contemporaneo.
Quindi c'è questa enorme opportunità
di efficientare il sistema di mobilità.
Auto autonoma,
auto automatica: dove siamo?
Oggi siamo quasi al livello tre.
Ci sono cinque livelli di automazione,
e noi siamo quasi al livello tre.
Cosa è il livello tre?
Il livello tre è una sorta
di pilota automatico
che noi potremmo inserire,
tipicamente in un ambiente autostradale,
e a quel punto potremmo, effettivamente,
disingaggiarci legalmente
e ufficialmente dalla guida
e quindi leggere il giornale
oppure mandare i messaggi,
o leggere la posta elettronica,
salvo poi essere reingaggiati
nel caso in cui il pilota automatico
non sia più in grado
di gestire la situazione.
Siamo quasi lì.
Capite che è un passaggio epocale,
perché in quel momento ci sarà
un passaggio di responsabilità,
e anche di assicurazione,
fra il pilota umano e il pilota
di Intelligenza Artificiale.
Da lì in avanti ci sarà un lungo cammino
verso il livello quattro
e il livello cinque.
Il livello cinque
è l'auto completamente autonoma:
di fatto non avrà più il volante,
non avrà più i pedali.
È un percorso molto complicato
perché, se ci pensate,
tra tutte le operazioni che noi facciamo
quello di guidare all'interno
di un traffico complesso
è in qualche modo
una delle cose più difficili.
Quindi, arrivare a un livello
di totale capacità di replicare
un umano nella guida
richiederà ancora 10-15 anni.
È la sfida tecnologica
di gran lunga piu grande
che tutto il mondo dell’automotive
dovrà affrontare nei prossimi 10, 20 anni.
Volevo citarvi, a tale proposito,
un evento un po' particolare
che è capitato quest'anno.
C'è stata la nascita
del cosiddetto "motosport autonomo",
cioè la gara fra auto
completamente autonome.
Ve lo cito perché non è solo un gioco,
un qualcosa per fare entertainment,
ma di fatto rappresenta
un'importante piattaforma di sviluppo
di quelle situazioni molto difficili,
di casi cosiddetti di emergenza.
Pensate: in autostrada, alta velocità,
tante macchine, bassa aderenza -
succede qualcosa di inaspettato.
Un'auto autonoma, su cui starete seduti
fra qualche decina di anni,
deve decidere cosa fare
in maniera molto rapida,
in quel momento lì.
Il racing autonomo ci aiuterà
per risolvere questo problema,
molto raro ma estremamente complicato.
Arrivati a questo punto, in realtà,
volevo cambiare pagina.
Ho parlato fino adesso
di mobilità fisica, e di come si evolverà:
ma in realtà noi sappiamo
che già prima della pandemia
era un processo in corso,
ma la pandemia lo ha
enormemente accelerato,
cioè il processo verso
la cosiddetta "mobilità virtuale".
Cos'è, è facile da capire:
non ci muoviamo più fisicamente,
ma si muove la voce, le immagini;
e magari, attraverso ologrammi,
la nostra figura tridimensionale.
Quindi questa è la mobilità virtuale,
che potenzialmente sostituisce
la mobilità fisica delle persone.
Quindi, se da un lato la mobilità fisica
avrà un processo che chiamerò,
con un neologismo, di “uberizzazione”,
cioè verso una mobilità a servizio,
dall'altro lato, probabilmente,
si espanderà molto rapidamente
un altro tipo di mobilità
che anche qui, con un neologismo,
fatemi chiamare “amazonizzazione”.
Cosa vuol dire?
Le persone si muoveranno sempre di meno,
ma a questo punto gli oggetti
dovranno raggiungere le persone.
E quindi ci sarà una crescita
esponenziale, già in atto,
di tutto quello che è il trasporto
e la mobilità della logistica:
non si muovono le persone,
ma si muovono le cose.
Quindi, aspettatevi in futuro
che la tecnologia svilupperà
non solo auto autonome,
che ci trasportano,
ma anche oggetti per trasportare
in modo completamente automatico le cose,
Vedete qui piccoli robot
che consegnano la pizza,
oppure, in maniera un po' più visionaria -
questa è una visione della  Continental -
addirittura il cane robot postino
che vi consegna il pacco
nella cassetta delle lettere.
Facciamo un gioco.
Proviamo a immaginarci,
ad aver la possibilità
di proiettarci fra 30 anni
in una delle nostre città;
e domandiamoci cosa vedremo,
che scenari potremmo vedere.
Ve ne propongo due.
Poi, quale sarà quello giusto
lo scopriremo fra trenta anni.
Scenario numero uno, questo.
Le città saranno sgombre dalle macchine:
ce ne saranno poche, piccole,
elettriche, automatiche,
estremamente sicure -
e quindi non colpiranno bambini,
cani, biciclette, eccetera eccetera.
Città libere per la cosiddetta
mobilità dolce, o la mobilita attiva.
Quindi andare a passeggio,
usare biciclette, biciclette elettriche,
gli scooter e così via.
Questo è lo scenario numero uno.
C'è un secondo scenario nel quale, invece,
avrà in qualche modo vinto,
avrà preso il sopravvento
la mobilità digitale;
e quindi vivremo la nostra mobilità
in mondi paralleli abitati da avatar,
da metaversi e cose di questo tipo.
Vi faccio notare
che in questo secondo scenario,
più o meno inquietante -
qui ognuno può dire la sua,
non esprimo giudizi -
ci sarà il paradosso di città
che saranno fittamente popolate,
ma paradossalmente con le strade
probabilmente deserte,
perché tutto andrà
verso una mobilità virtuale.
Ovviamente ci saranno i piccoli robot,
che porteranno le pizza a casa,
ma sostanzialmente le strade
saranno deserte
dalla mobilità delle persone.
Ci sarà un altro motivo,
questo molto probabile,
per cui le città in qualche modo
si svuoteranno della loro popolazione,
o comunque verrà invertito un trend.
Lo vedete in questa figura:
negli ultimi 50 anni,
c'è stato un incessante trend
verso l’urbanizzazione,
cioè le persone si sono,
progressivamente, sempre spostate
dalle aree rurali alle città.
È molto probabile, e il post pandemia
lo sta dimostrando,
che ci sarà un'inversione di tendenza
verso le aree rurali,
perché ci sono,
e ci saranno sempre di più,
lavori che possono essere fatti
in modo completamente digitale.
A quel punto, un lavoro
completamente digitale
permette al lavoratore di essere
completamente distaccato,
destrutturato rispetto al luogo di lavoro.
Queste nuove figure
vengono anche detti "nomadi digitali",
perché si possono permettere il nomadismo:
il loro lavoro non cambia,
è sempre lo stesso,
ma di fatto non è associato
a una precisa posizione geografica.
E a questo punto questi nomadi digitali,
questa nuova categoria di lavoratori,
potrà tranquillamente permettersi
di decidere di ritornare in campagna.
Quindi potremmo vedere
le nostre città depopolate,
ripopolate le campagne:
ma non di contadini,
ma di questi nomadi digitali
che essenzialmente lavoreranno
con strumenti digitali
davanti un computer.
Una provocazione, una domanda.
Progettare e definire oggi
un grosso parcheggio cittadino,
che magari verrà deliberato fra due anni
e verrà costruito,
e finalmente messo in opera,
verso la fine di questo decennio,
è una buona idea?
Pensateci su o ragionateci sopra.
Grazie.
(Applausi)